(techno music)
- [Man] Thank you, Gary.
- Morning.
So, the interesting part
was when I was looking at the
profile of who's in the audience
and I actually was in the back
room like, "Hey, can we just do
all Q&amp;A," because I think the
fact of the matter is a stunning
majority of the people sitting
out here could be doing
what I'm doing and vice versa.
And so, I think what I'll do
is I'll talk a little bit about
where I see things and really
try to create a framework for
maybe the Q&amp;A session which
I think will
bring even more value.
So my career started in a very
entrepreneurial way and there
was no media metrics,
there was no awards,
there was no proxy other
than did the marketing I did
sell more wine for my
dad's liquor store.
That was the KPI.
And so, my background
of selling baseball cards and
then building a wine business.
For context, I built
Wine Library a wine business
I launched in 1996.
I really started running it in
1998 and in a five year window
from '98 to 2003 I built
my dad's local liquor store
which had no money.
We were doing
$3 million a year in revenue,
10% gross profit.
So you have
$300,000 before expenses.
My first year's marketing
budget literally was $14,000.
So this is a
very small business.
And in 1998 to 2003 on the back
of a very young internet and
looking around the
crowd, I'm sure some of,
a good majority of you
remember that early internet,
it's nothing compared to
what we're dealing with today.
I was able to
build that business from
a 3 to $60 million business.
And I did it on ad
tech and marketing.
I did because Google Adwords
came out and I bought the word
"wine" for five cents a click
before they raised the minimum.
And I learned a lot
from '96 to 2004.
I had an email newsletter
that had 91% open rates.
Because it was 1997 and nobody
was doing email marketing and my
whole career has basically
been find new frontiers.
Be the guy that buys
four beachfront
properties in Malibu
when nobody sees it,
believe in that,
develop it, wait and then be
very excited that people are
buying seven streets
away from the beach
for 10 times the price.
And build a framework that is
actually profitable to allow me
to hold my breath for 24 to
36 or 48 months to let the
consumers catch
up to my beliefs.
What has been stunning to me in
the last seven years that I've
now been involved in running
an agency and working with the
clients like PepsiCo and
Unilever and Toyota and Chase
and things of that nature is
I didn't realize how lucky
I was as an entrepreneur.
For VaynerMedia, I was able
to, over the last five years,
grow us from 22 people to 800
people from $3 million to
$100 million in revenue because
I can continue to do my model.
I can do what I did this last
year which is grow Vayner
from 67 to 100
but make less money
'cause I'm an entrepreneur.
I have no board or publicly
traded product that allows me to
only be stuck in 90 day or
180 day or 365 day behavior.
I believe this entire conference
and this entire space is broken,
not in a bad way.
Broken from the way I see the
world because everything is
based on the
short-term behavior.
And everything is based on data
that isn't actually practical to
the reality of the business.
How many more times are you guys
going to go into a meeting where
the math within the ecosystem
that you play looks positive.
It's going well, the ROAS
is amazing but the person's
business is in the tank?
And to me that disconnect and
the fact that our clients and
the market has
to worry about 60,
90, 180, 365 day behavior
and the fact that so many,
the first meeting I was
ever in in this industry
I sat through an IAT
with a bunch of different
agencies and everybody presented
and I literally thought the
business had quadrupled in the
last year and then
I'm pretty ADD'ed out,
I went the last page of the
slide and the business was down
17% yet everybody was
Kumbaya-ing around math and
metrics that had
nothing to fucking do
with the actual business.
And so to me, what I'm
fascinated by is I only do one
move and I would challenge so
many of you in this room whether
you're 100% all-in
on this, like I am,
or 19 move to 25,
please if I can bring
any value in any way
we need to start
having a bigger debate
around a couple of things.
One, common sense needs to
start entering our ecosystem.
What is fundamentally different
in this Corporate America,
ad tech, B2B environment
that I now find myself in
unlike the entrepreneurial
Silicon Valley world
I came from,
the common sense
factor seems to be zero.
The behavior is so predicated on
what's in the best interest of
the person at that moment
working within that machine.
Whether on the client
side or the salesperson.
The amount of person that sit
in this room and actually
deep down, you know,
deep down lie detector,
your children's health on
the line don't believe in what
they're selling is stunning.
And to me that's fascinating.
That's just an
interesting debate.
It also speaks to
something that everybody
should be paying attention to.
Which is, we are going to a very
different interesting channel
conflict decade or
two that's emerging.
So much is about to go DTC.
So many of the clients that we
trade on are about to go direct
to consumer over
the next 20 years.
How many people
here, real quick,
so I can figure out
where I want to take this talk,
how many people here are
retiring in the next 10 years?
And I don't mean you're gonna
crush it and sell your company
and buy a boat.
I mean you're fucking
old and you're finished.
(audience laughter)
10 years?
Raise your hand.
That's what I thought.
It looks like it's zero.
Where do you think the
world is gonna be in 10 years?
And so, we need to start caring
about the consumer a lot more.
My biggest problem with the
way I have defined historically
programmatic or
things of that nature
is I lived in 1997
internet where I was getting
in certain websites 11% click
through on banner ads. Right?
We're living in a
world where a lot of people,
a lot of people
think I'm a digitalist and
I don't like traditional media.
Yes, I do not like a
television commercial.
I think it's overpriced
for the attention that
I day trade every day.
But I equally don't
like a banner ad. At all.
I just don't believe common
sense-wise that anybody actually
is consuming that product.
And by the way, the
things I love in stream,
Facebook or Instagram,
that's going to go away too.
Because this is one big
game of cat and mouse. Right?
Email worked 'cause
nobody was doing it.
I got 90% open rates.
Here I am 15 years later and
I have 31% open rates and
that's pretty darn good.
This is what's
always gonna happen.
And so, I think in general
what's fascinating to me is
what's gonna play
out in the next year.
That if you're a practitioner,
that is you don't actually just
read headlines in the
14 magazines and websites
we all read, that if you really
had to sell to
survive you would
realize that the most
underpriced ad product in the
world right now is
Facebook advertising.
That if you had to sell
something to stay alive to feed
your children, you would put
your money there if you were a
full-time practitioner
across all the options.
Google search is incredible
and I love it but when you start
understanding the difference
between sales and marketing and
start understanding that
Facebook is the first platform
that's come
along that can do both,
it's quite impressive.
When you then say the next thing
that you would look at most
likely is influencers on
Instagram and getting them to
give you product
placement or shout out.
If you actually
traded on everything,
if you actually
spent money on everything.
These debates matter because
what happens is you start
realizing that if you reverse
engineer the consumer's actual
attention then you have a much
better chance of succeeding.
And so, I sit in rooms every
single day if I was willing to
pander and if I had a different
mission at hand like build the
biggest agency
I could and sell it,
we would be doing a lot more
revenue 'cause it's very easy to
sell to the market what they
actually want to buy versus what
I actually want to sell them
which is the thing that I think
most sells product and
so I think as a macro and
I'm going very high level,
I would just like more debate
about math being only one part
of the equation and I'm just
stunned by the enormous amount
of times we're spending and just
to remind every marketer in this
room if math was what marketing
is, this would've been
figured out a long time ago.
A long, long time ago.
And so, I'm stunned by the fact
that everybody throws around
metrics on how good your
product's working and we don't
deploy the part that
matters the most which is
was it actually consumed?
I understand that you threw it
in front of some screen that
I potentially saw it
but was it consumed?
And that plays in
traditional channels.
I'll tell you as a weird side
note the number one rabbit hole
I'm in right now
is live read radio
during drive time radio.
To me as an underpriced asset as
those prices continue to go down
'cause people think it's dead.
They're actually being consumed
'cause you want to talk about
real native advertising,
the jockey reading while
you're listening to the station.
For me, I have this funny
very unemotional thing, right?
Even the thing I'm
most excited about,
in a weird way even though I
trade on Facebook and Instagram
and Snapchat and things of that
nature, I'm not hurt even though
I wrote a $5 million check
into Snapchat that Snapchat is
declining a little bit
because of feature changes on
Instagram world.
It's just the market.
The market is the
market is the market.
Where I think a lot of
people here as they come,
as Vayner has now become
a bigger media spender as
we continue to
spend money in media,
not just be a creative shop,
I've come to meet a lot of your
company's and a lot of angel,
and when walking in to our
organization, I've been
fascinated by the way that
people are
positioning their product.
One of the
biggest things I learned,
when I was building Wine Library
with Google and it was the great
reason I didn't be a PMD on top
of Facebook is there's nobody
here that's going to out develop
the platforms themselves.
When you're building on
the mercy of these platforms.
Have you not seen the historical
nature of what happened with
Google and Twitter
like these platforms?
Listen, I come from that world.
I promise you here's how the
founders talk at 2 o'clock in
the morning at SXSW.
I'm gonna let all these fucking
idiots build on top my platform,
I'm gonna pick the best one.
I'm going to tell them that
if they don't sell to me on a
nickel on a dollar I'm
gonna buy their competitor.
Have you read
the API access TOS?
You can't do
anything you're doing.
They're letting you do it in
their vested interest and so
I think there's a lot of
interesting macro trends that
are going on that when I say
those things I'm watching a lot
of smart people
kinda shake their head,
have that nod like you know
and I get that and so I ask and
implore this room to
do a couple of things.
Number one, the only thing I do
for a living is try to reverse
engineer what
brings value to a customer.
And by nature,
advertising does not do that.
In a world where
it has been proven,
my great angel investing mistake
so far is that I passed on Uber
at $4 million
valuation twice. Right?
I left a lot of
money on the table.
I invested in it a little bit
later so hopefully I'll do okay
but it was when I realized that
Uber wasn't a transportation
company, Uber was selling
time is why I made the bet.
Right now if you
look at your behavior,
nothing is more
important besides time.
Time has become the emerging
thing outside of health and
well-being of your
family and money,
time has become the newest
and emerging and has the most
momentum of value to all of us.
Watch this?
How many people in this room
by show of hands now get
angry when somebody calls them?
Raise your hand.
Raise your hand high. High.
I want everybody to see this.
Higher. You guys
are half-assing it.
Look at this,
these are human beings,
thank you, that are upset that
another human being called them
because they subconsciously
understand that we now live in a
technology world
where you are stealing,
why are you bothering me?
Why don't you hit me up on text?
Maybe email and I'll
get back to you on my time,
don't bother me.
You don't know what
I'm doing right now.
Like, "Mom, what the
fuck are you doing?"
"Text me."
You know, like that?
That's where we're at.
So if you were actually upset
more than 70% of this room,
upset, that somebody calls you
which is very easy for you to
get away from,
you just silence it,
put it down and these are most
likely either people you love,
like or solidly know
you're telling me
that we as human beings
are excited to go to
ESPN.com and have a piece of
shit banner ad pop-up that we
can't get away from and now
we're mobiled out, right?
I don't know if you guys have
been paying attention but those
little X's are small as shit.
And so when you go to click it
you're actually
clicking into the ad.
And so back in
Nerdsville, Mathland
everyone's like, "Oh, shit. 2.3%
click through ratio, yeah."
Meanwhile, that
consumer hates your brand.
Because that
brand stole their time.
And so we trade in this
collective on math and we don't
deploy any common sense.
And really, what
really pisses me off,
we actually don't give a shit if
the stuff is selling or not and
you know it's even scarier?
I actually don't
really blame you
'cause it's not your business.
You should worry
about your business.
The brand manager and CMOs
don't actually give a shit.
And that's the punchline.
The punchline is does
your product or service work to
somebody's in a position where
their life depends on selling
stuff because
of your technology?
Not their job, how
many brand managers,
CMO's, chief media
offers tell me to my face,
to my face, that the decisions
they're making have far more to
do with how they're scored
internally on their MMM or
whatever else, not what they
actually believe is in the
best interest of their business.
That is not the
world I come from.
That is not the world that
my family immigrated to this
country could live on.
There was none of that
and that's the great stunning,
intriguing thing for
me and this marketplace.
And so, to me,
that's what I combat.
Everybody thinks
I'm loud or a futurist or
I'm irreverent or this and that.
I think I'm practical as fuck.
I think I'm completely
grounded in one thing,
does this communication create
the donation to the non-profit,
to me to buy this sneaker,
does it make you do something?
And I don't think them rest of
the market is trading on that
and I used to be mad.
I used to think I was smarter.
I realized neither
one of those are true.
I'm just put in a position,
I've put myself in a position to
actually care about that end
result and many others have to
based on their situation.
I'm not mad at somebody
who's making six figures,
has college loans and has to
pay for them or has a family to
support and internally this is
how it's scored or externally
this is how it's scored.
I'm not mad but just because
that's the game you're stuck
within or your client's stuck
within doesn't mean it's right.
And that is the friction.
And I implore everybody since
you're going to be here in
10 years in business to
realize that's gonna
start shedding itself out.
'Cause the biggest brands in the
world one little fun fact 97%,
95 to 97% of the
Fortune 500 CPG brands
lost market share last year.
'Cause they're throwing money in
the garbage because you've got
four to five holding
companies and I'm not,
by the way, I'm not mad at the
biggest media
agencies in the world.
They're doing
what's right for them.
They're publicly traded too,
all the way up the ladder to the
holding company level.
They're gonna push the things
that make the biggest margin on.
Of course,
programmatic's exciting.
Good solid margins.
Of course up front
television's exciting.
Good solid margin.
You know what's not?
Really planning Facebook with
47 different cohorts and
creative against it. It's not.
I know it's not and by the
way, I'm not Mother Teresa.
The only reason we're doing is
'cause I don't
want to build an agency.
I want to buy the brands
eventually and run them through
my machine and
do private equity.
So, it's not that I'm
this great noble dude.
I'm trying to
buy the fucking Jets.
And so I'm on my own kick
but I know it's right because
I know when I A/B test
and I know when I look at it,
I know that we're trading on
metrics that are not practical
and so again, to be on
the right side of history,
to have leverage,
I'm asking the industry
to start debating why
does it look good and that's
why I like things like Moat and
their ambitions and
things of that nature.
Like we have to
get to this place.
I can't wait 'til we all have
chips in our head or wearing
virtual reality contact lenses
or whatever were doing where the
math really plays out,
did we actually consume it?
Did we actually give a shit?
I know we're not in that world
and most of us won't see that
during our careers but that is
the only place I think about and
that's why the stuff I bet on
are much more predicated on a
whole lot of intuitive
understanding of what will drive
the emotion of consumer.
And it's also why I completely,
completely am infatuated with
the creative because once
we get in front of people,
look, this keynote,
I've got your attention.
That worked. That was the
framework of this but if the
content sucked I would lose.
So the creative is
the variable of success.
The problem is that has its
own major issues because the
majority of creative is made for
the sake of that agency getting
new employees or
new clients. Right?
We have a very intriguing, very
intriguing world that I've found
myself in the last half decade.
I'm enjoying it I love the
people in it I just think that
we have to have more challenging
conversations because I believe
that we're not doing enough in
the best interest of our clients
and they're already starting
with not caring enough about
their actual own businesses and
so we're left in a place where
people are struggling and so,
something has to change to do
the right work and these
conversations need to happen so
I'm looking to
throw them out there.
I know I went pretty high
level, I've got five minutes.
I did want to answer one or two
specific questions if anybody
has any detailed questions about
anything in social or things of
that nature I'd love
to answer them now
but thanks for
listening. Thank you.
(audience applause)
Anybody have a question?
Like if you have context on
some of the spiel I talk about
outside of this talk.
This gentleman right over here.
He's coming up from behind you.
What is your name?
- [Kevin] Hi, my
name's Kevin Rippy.
I'm with Nomura Instinet.
- [Gary] How are you?
- The question is you
say Facebook is the cheapest
inventory on the internet.
- [Gary] I believe so, yes.
- By what order of magnitude?
- [Gary] In comparison
to the others?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm not sure.
Here's what I know that I'm
involved with a lot of early
stage startups that
need to create transactions.
I have my personal brand
that tries to sell books or
things of that nature.
I have the wine business and
I have the $200 million we spent
last year and
watched it pretty carefully.
What I am most fascinated
by when I sell selling,
look, Google intent based
selling is incredible. Right?
If I'm looking to
buy wine, I'm searching,
that's incredible.
What I don't we've understood
and what we don't deploy enough
about is the collateral damage
of ads as they've been in the
ecosystem for a
long period of time.
Facebook has a sweet
spot right now, right?
What it has is it is so much
scale the biggest brands in the
world are still
debating dumb shit and
aren't pouring real money in.
When you look at
who's getting the benefit,
when you look at
a company like Wish,
the shopping app, that goes from
zero to $2 billion in revenue on
the back of 100% Facebook
advertising and so I look a lot
of those proxies and so when
I've A/B tested $3 million
spend on Facebook versus
$3 million DMA spend
on local commercials
or when we've done $500,000
on Facebook versus $500,000 on
Google and things of that nature
the things that excites me is
I don't care about just
the first transaction.
The thing that a lot of
people, last touch attribution.
Do you know how
fucked up that is?
(audience laughter)
Like enough.
It's completely, we've become
so transactional because math is
not debatable and so we use it
as a proxy and as a leverage but
it's not telling the full
story of what's happening.
And so what
Facebook does, listen,
if you're a big brand, if you're
Nike Facebook's bad because it's
blue letters and you're
losing the brand equity that you
actually trade on,
in a Google environment.
On Facebook you can
go DR but you can also,
all the upside.
We were so lucky to have ABI as
a client when Lucas and Ricardo
are actually creating an
opportunity for us to make a
three minute video when the
Cubs win the World Series,
TV commercials work, the problem
is nobody watches those anymore.
So you have to replicate
it in a 2017 environment.
That is Facebook's game to win.
Two and three and four
minute videos that actually mean
something to you that
don't look like a commercial.
Like, right now Vayner do you
remember when the Supreme Court
Justice said years ago,
"I can't define porn but
"when I see it I know
what it is," that whole thing.
That's I'm doing
it Vayner right now.
Zero commercials.
We're making videos
on Facebook to sell shit.
I can't really define
it for you Vayner.
I'm approving every video for
the next six months and the
punchline is if it feels
like a commercial to me at all,
it's not getting through.
Show me documentaries.
Show me scenes from a sitcom.
You want to sell a cocktail,
show me as seen from
"Sex and the City"
in a 2017 environment.
Show me something people will
actually watch because what
we're doing is,
I love when people say
Facebook's metrics are off.
I'm like none of
that shit matters.
I don't give a fuck if they
score on three seconds views,
10 seconds views.
People are like,
"Google's better," I'm like,
"Google's forcing you to
watch that before you watch
"what you actually want.
"You're not
actually consuming it.
"You're just letting it play
through so you can watch the
"fucking skiing video."
We are just not
deploying common sense.
And what blows me away is
everybody in this room as a
human when you're not wearing
your job description on your
name tag and when you're human,
like Saturday you know exactly
what's going on.
You get in Monday and you have
financial vested interest to
push a different thing and
that's where people going into.
I don't know the full magnitude
one thing I've got better is not
talking about shit I don't know.
What I do know is this.
I'm telling you if people wanted
to build their family business
they would spend every
penny that they could on
Facebook right now.
The great mistake of my career
is I love standing in front of
you and saying I grew my dad's
business from $3 to $60 million
the truth is it should
have been $3 to $300 million.
I spent too much money on direct
mail and outdoor and radio and
banners when I had the Google
arbitrage and it was at scale.
I wasn't smart
enough to go pot committed.
I'm not a poker player but when
you have the best fuckin' hand,
you put it all in.
I'm spending every fucking penny
that I have full control of on
Facebook and Instagram
influencers and nothing else
because the spread
on the day trading part
right now is so extreme.
It is so underpriced.
And then you have people
that think it's overpriced or
you have somebody that reads a
headline that
Procter &amp; Gamble is changing.
It's just sheep mentality of
a bunch of fucking headline
readers that don't know what
the fuck they're talking about.
People have opinions on
Snapchat ads in this room
they've never run one.
They've never looked at it.
They've never
seen the full funnel to
did it sell 8,000 pairs
of fucking sneakers, asshole?
They don't know,
they don't know.
What they're saying is what's in
their vested interest and for me
the only thing that I was smart
about is I'm just trying to be
historically correct as
leverage to do business
over the next 50 years.
So I'll say, I don't know,
I just change my mind every day.
I'll sell anything.
You want to buy rocks?
I'll sell them to you.
I don't have any emotion.
I don't allow, that's
why didn't build the tech.
I didn't allow myself to
be boxed into one thing.
I'm selling attention and
if that's drive
time radio, Mazel Tov.
If that's fucking
newspapers what to sell $4 ads,
I'll buy 'em.
'Cause that's the right price,
you know what I mean?
Cool.
This gentleman right here
and then I'll get out of here.
Oh shit, I'm already -20.
I'll go real fast.
Yeah mic, mic.
- Huge fan.
Talked to a lot of my clients
about day trading for attention.
They come back to us and say
okay well if you're a financial
services guy, you're doing
predictive stuff ahead of
day trading, ahead of
this, ahead of that.
And so we've been
looking at ways to take agile,
iterative approaches
into predicting,
trending hashtags,
trending keywords.
- [Gary] Cool.
- Before it even happens
so a quick example to make it
clear to everybody, if we know
Hurricane Matthew is coming in
two weeks, three weeks,
we buy the keywords.
- [Gary] Yep, I get it.
- [Man] We start
selling duct tape,
and glow sticks, water before--
- I get it, yep. Yep.
- [Man] How does that, are
you doing something like that?
- We're doing
that around culture.
So that's super
practical and smart and
I would call that transactional.
And I love that shit, I do it
for Wine Library quite a bit.
I'm much more
into that culturally.
It's understanding that
shadowboxing is happening.
meditation as a consumer trend
in the way that Soul Cycle and
health happened is a trend and
so we're making a lot of bets.
It's understanding that 14 of
Atlanta's hip hop artists are
about to become the
next Drakes and Lil Waynes.
We're doing it a little bit
more creatively and culturally.
It has more upside
and more downside.
The transaction stuff
I think is massively interesting.
The problem is for everybody in
this room most of their clients
don't sell the entire funnel.
- [Man] Right.
- Right?
When you're a CPG brand, you're
not selling it direct consumer.
You're selling it through CVS
and that's why were at the mercy
of all these metrics.
The problem is the
metrics and the sales,
don't match up.
That has to be talked about.
It has to be talked about.
Anyway, there's other people,
I don't want to be rude.
- [Man] Thanks.
- Thank you.
Have a great day, guys.
(audience applause)
(jazz music)